le cinéaste italien ettore scola tourne
actuellement auprès de senlis un film
sur l'avènement de la révolution
française film coproduit par fr3 ettore
scola a choisi un événement la fuite du
roi louis saez à varennes le 21 juin
1791 autour de la berline royal on
trouve des personnages assez inattendue
du séducteur casanova au démocrate
américain thomas spain
il s'agit d'une reconstitution
imaginaire de cet épisode de l'histoire
de france mais on y verra les moeurs de
l'époque et un certain regard sur
l'écroulement de la monarchie et la
révolution française une équipe de fr3
mien a assisté au début du tournage de
ce film à la distribution brillante et
internationale l'église des consacrés de
s'inscrire à senlis a pour une semaine
retrouver son passé et sert donc de
décor à l'une des scènes du film
d'ettore scola l'église saint lysienne
est devenu le relais de chatrix l'une
des messageries royal où le roi louis
saez en fuite
vite escale sur la route de vars est 90
figurants participent au tournage crise
coeur de cette coproduction franco
italienne marcello mastroianni ordre est
altérée hommes hannachi lula et jean
claude brialy notamment font partie
d'une trésorerie en distribution
je joue le rôle du coiffeur jacob qui
est qui accompagnent
d'un contest ce qui est la lectrice de
la reine marie antoinette
je fais partie à la fois de des gens
privilégiés en même temps les
domestiques mais qui était à l'époque
des plus les confidences des amis ou
parfois des bouffons en réalité lorsque
le film sortira pour noël en principe on
s'apercevra qu'à aucun moment louis saez
et son carrosse n'apparaisse à l'écran
c'est le trait de génie de scola et tori
scola convient de voir en pleine action
en train de diriger son film a fait là
quelque chose dont on a toujours élevé
lorsqu'on était lycéen
c'est mélanger différentes périodes de
l'histoire est arrivé à se faire
rencontrer des personnages qui n'ont
jamais vécu la même époque
ainsi on retrouvera casanova sous les
traits de marcello mastroianni qui
répond à recife de la bretonne et ainsi
de suite
l'intérêt de ce film n'est pas dans une
reconstitution historique
au sens strict du terme mais au
contraire dans le bouleversement de
toutes ces époques
cela prend la forme à la fois d'un film
picaresque d'un débat philosophique et
c'est surtout intéressant parce que
cette fuite à varennes en quelque sorte
oskola c'est la fuient des grands
possédants d'aujourd'hui qui rêvent de
trouver refuge dans un pays idéal
ils seraient pas poursuivis par la
révolution on connaît ce col à travers
ses films de cannes
on sait donc son propos sera marc si
l'état conclusion plutôt révolutionnaire